All right, welcome to another Zoom call.
Got a bunch of questions to go over.
Just a reminder, go to the member site for all the announcements.
If there's any changes, it will be on the member site.
And good news, all our labs are back and back in full force big time back
because now we can offer labs literally just at cost.
Rupa is who we have partnered with, who a lot of practitioners partner with.
And the benefit that they charge 7% above practitioner wholesale pricing.
So it's really nice.
And they ship the labs out, they ship the kits out so that saves us time as a clinic.
And they have even better videos than the lab has and how to do things that help you find
to local draw site, et cetera.
So that's really, really good.
Also, your supplements, you can get a 5% discount on all your supplements.
If you sign up for a subscription, all our supplements are the subscription model.
Now we just added, got that adding that for the last two months.
So that's all available now.
So you get the 5% discount on that too.
We were having troubles with our store website authorized dot.
That was having issues.
That's who our credit card processing goes through.
So we had to switch it to, it was just a total paid between over the weekend.
So that is all working now again.
And reminder, if you have any desire to order ortho molecular or biotic research products
or apex products contact us because those companies don't allow online sales
that they don't allow us to have them on the store, though we can sell the products.
We just can't have one store.
That's ridiculous, but that's their role.
So just call in your order and we'll help you with it, get that ordered.
Also, if there's any other products that you order somewhere else, if you don't see it on
our store, all us and we can see if we can get it for you.
All right, so let's get to some of the questions.
Remember, all our courses are available and the new course.
I think I'm super proud of it as all new material.
You are loved to have any issues with autoimmune disease.
You really need to look at that course.
These courses are all free to you guys.
So autoimmune course, got all new videos, all the content.
And the information on section, our module six, now Hashimoto's, is literally,
there's probably maybe 50 doctors in the world that know that information.
So it can be really helpful if you or a loved one has Hashimoto's or any autoimmune disease.
So make sure, if you have time, take a peek at those.
Also, our blog is back on our site.
Make sure you search the blog or anything.
We have almost 1,000 blog posts of information.
So you can't wait till next Wednesday for your question.
Might have already been answered in the blog post.
So look at that too.
Okay, first question.
On our call, we discussed the Dutch test for horrible, the Dutch test.
Which one do you suggest me to order the Dutch plus or the Dutch complete?
Also, you took me off the iodide on the breast.
But do I need to be taking some, do I need to be taking it internally for the thyroid?
Currently, I'm not at any other iodide supplement.
So the first question, what should you do, if you're going to do the Dutch test,
should you do the Dutch test plus this one here?
Or should you do the Dutch test complete?
So the Dutch complete is the one I typically recommend.
The plus adds some organic acid tests.
But it's not a complete organic acid test.
So I would just say just do the complete, the cheaper one, the 325.
This is the one I have everybody do is the complete, it's the organic acid test.
That's included in this.
It doesn't have enough tests for me to justify adding the $100.
We're going to do an organic acid test and do a full organic acid test around great planes.
So that's that first question.
Do the complete, the cheaper one, the less expensive one.
You took me off the iodide on the breast, yes, I did.
But do I need to be taking it internally for the thyroid?
Well, should anybody be taking the iodide for the thyroid?
Well, what you're going to find is all the new information.
This course right here, module six, I lay out in great detail.
Why no one should be taking iodine at all.
The only time you should be taking iodides for a short period of time for breast cancer
but nobody else should be taking iodine.
Nobody should be taking iodine for their thyroid gland.
And I won't go into any greater detail in that.
And I know some of you who have been in functional medicine for a while go,
what that makes sense?
Of course, everybody needs iodine.
Yes, you need iodine to make T3, but you need such a little amount.
You should not be taking any exogenous iodine.
You need any supplemental iodine at all, zero, none.
So don't be taking iodine.
You want a more information on that,
go to module six on the automobile course.
Currently, I'm not on the other iodine supplement.
That's exactly right.
That's what I wanted.
By Iravec, doctor tested all my supplements via electrodermal testing.
How does this compare to kinesiology?
Well, it's just different.
So electrodermal testing is you put your hand on a cradle
and you test a supplement.
And it can test positive or negative for you.
And it's just a different way to test with kinesiology.
We lock with my kinesiology, I lock into your body
then lock into cancer.
And we're tested against cancer.
We're not testing the supplements just in random.
So it's tested against your cancer.
So that's the difference on how we do kinesiology.
That being said, there's all sorts of different practitioners
that do kinesiology that just personally I wouldn't trust.
So I mean, it isn't art form that you have to trust the person doing it.
I would have the 35 supplements that I'm taking.
He said my body only responded well to four.
And I should only take those four.
So what should I do?
I really don't know what to do.
Since I've purchased all these supplements already.
Well, again, I'm not ever telling anybody here
that you got to do it my way or you got to make that decision
of what you got to do.
You trusted me to test you.
And it came back the testing that came back.
And you're going to somebody else to test you too
that you got to just decide what you want to do.
So I can't tell you, no, you need to do this.
Your body knows if you need to make that decision,
if that practitioner is being kind of arrogant to say,
this is all you should be doing.
You should be doing it well, then you're going to make that decision.
I can't, I'm not going to get into it
or give it between practitioners.
So you decide what you want to do.
Veterizideo is the drug that my oncologist may recommend for me.
Please see the screen shots.
Yes, I did.
I saw the email of that.
What do you think about that with dim
to regulate my hormones instead of tamoxifen?
Is Veterizideo okay or not good?
Well, remember the law.
I can't comment on drugs.
So if it's a prescription medication
that's something you have to talk to your prescribing doctor
about, that's where I have to draw the line
with our, just with our medical legal perspective
that we cannot be saying, oh yeah, that's a good drug.
You should take that drug or don't ever take that drug.
And then you, you know, that gets back
and it's just, I can't legally do that.
So I'm not a prescribing doctor.
So you have to talk to a prescribing doctor about that.
With any drug, we always recommend that you Google it
and you Google the side effects of it
and you Google any studies you can find about it.
So, but I apologize.
We just have to stay medical legal on that.
In the seventh space is a detoxification course.
Hey, great.
You say that a phase six colds forward is not
is intended for short-term use only
what's considered long-term use?
Okay, so the reason why it stated that it's
for short-term use is solely because of this edit right here,
this Cape Aloe.
Cape Aloe is a type of aloe that is really good
at drawing water into the colon and lucidity to your mouth.
So we have another product.
It's a, we have a private label from Ortho Molecular.
It's their super aloe 250.
It's our phase six assist.
And that is 250 milligrams of Cape Aloe.
This two capsules has has 50 milligrams.
The other one is just straight Cape Aloe.
It doesn't have this trifolio in it
and it is 250 milligrams Cape Aloe per capsule.
Now I have some people taking two of those a day
and they would take a two of those a day for the last two years.
There's nothing wrong with staying on it long term
if you need to.
If you know why you have issues,
the people that are doing that have colon issues,
they're not ignoring the fact that they have colon issues.
They're dealing with that,
but when you have colon cancer or something like that,
you need to keep your bottles loose.
There's nothing wrong with staying on Cape Aloe long term.
It's just all the manufacturers had to put it in there
that it's not meant for long term use.
And it's really because if you have that chronic constipation
that you have to be taking a laxative of any type,
long term, you're not dealing with the reason why
you have the chronic constipation.
That is not correct management.
But if you have chronic constipation
because you have colon cancer or something like that,
you already know that we're trying to deal with that.
There's nothing wrong with staying on that.
This is actually much lower,
but any company that uses Cape Aloe says
it's not tended for long term use.
Certainly this product here could be used long term.
I'd like this product because it's only got 50 milligrams
of the Cape Aloe, which is really good for healing the gut
and the magnesium which draws water into the gut.
So this is a really good product
for just my own constipation issues.
Even with the space six assist,
I don't recommend people take it on a daily basis
or some people do.
Most people take it just when they feel like they're backed up,
they ate a bunch of meat or something like that,
that tends to back them up a little bit
and they take that for a couple of days
to clean themselves out.
You could certainly take this long term,
this product long term.
There's nothing really wrong with that.
This one, I've lost all my desire to eat,
not sure what to do.
So when we lose our desire to eat,
and or we find ourselves losing weight
and we can't keep weight on,
that is typically a sign of caquexia.
The definition of caquexia is
when you're losing two to four pounds a week,
no matter what you eat,
you can't keep your weight on it.
You just keep losing weight.
So caquexia is a phenomena in chronic illness and cancer.
And there's no perfect definition
of why physiologically that it takes place.
I wrote a blog post about this.
So go to the blog section here,
right there, search caquexia in the blog post
and I have a video even on that blog.
There's a picture of the video.
It just took a screenshot of the blog post.
Watch that video,
because I give a bunch of hints to deal with weight loss
and when I lose my desire to eat,
we just have to remember you're eating to live
regardless of whether you feel hungry or not.
So make sure you don't stop eating.
You can't get in a state where you're losing weight
on a weekly basis.
That is very detrimental.
We don't want to get into that state.
So watch that video.
There's some different exercises
you can do some different things that you can do
that can be really helpful.
My town now has an IV in Puget Mara.
Would vitamin C with glutathione, IV be good
or bad for colon cancer?
It would be good.
There would be no downsides of this.
So even though maybe it didn't test well
with panesiology as a big positive,
there could be other positives.
Remember, I'm locking into specific cancer when I test.
It can be good for other things in your body.
Certainly, glutathione is your number one antioxidant
in all your intercellular spaces.
It's super important for your lungs and such,
which the way I'm talking right now,
I think I need to take some glutathione.
But that could be a real big benefit.
So yeah, go for it.
That would be great.
Okay, questions on the chat.
Is it okay to do base rejuvenation
with hyaluronic acid injections?
It is going to, is it going to affect the tumor?
I don't know how hyaluronic acid breaks down metabolicly.
I'm not a big fan of any injections like this.
Boy, that's a toughy.
I'd have to do some research to see how that breaks down
if it's possible.
So a lot of the injections, like Botox injections,
it's not uncommon for that to cause autoimmune diseases.
And I'm not sure about the hyaluronic acid.
I know more of taking it orally is no problem.
I just don't know about injecting it.
I guess I don't have an answer for that I apologize.
Are you familiar with Dr. Talba's cigarette?
Yes, what are your thoughts on him say
that no tumor can survive if you're in ketosis,
no glucose and glutamine?
Well, the only thing I don't like about his book
he wrote was it the metabolic something of cancer
or something like that.
He doesn't practice.
He's just a researcher.
So he doesn't actually seek cancer patients.
It is book he only had an example of one cancer patient
who had smoldering multiple myeloma.
It's not a good example as having one decay study
to work through with your book.
And I am totally in agreement that many times,
especially if you have HIF1G defects
and you're gonna be way more prone to
or your cancer to be feeding on the end stage
and glycolysis just feeding off a lactic acid
because you don't convert lactic acid
into a single coenzyme A very quickly.
That going on a more ketogenic diet can be helpful.
So if nobody's read his book, except the person
who asked the question, he's a really,
he thinks every cancer patient should call
a ketogenic diet.
And to me, whenever anybody says a comment like that,
it's an instant red flag.
Because every human being is different
and a cancer is different, I don't care if you
and your twin brother have colon cancer,
it can be completely different in your two bodies.
So it's just not, when you make blanket statements like that,
to me it shows a little bit of ignorance in real life practice.
So I guess that was all I'd say about that.
I just disagree with that.
I think everybody is different.
Some people's bodies, their cancer speed
totally different than other people.
So I just don't necessarily agree with it.
I was too told through your genetic testing
that a keto diet would be good for me.
OK, so who's asking this question?
I don't remember your genetics.
You may have a lot of HIF1 gene defects.
So going on a ketogenic diet is something you could do.
And you don't have to go full ketogenic
and get into ketosis.
You could just do kind of a modified ketogenic diet.
That's where intermittent fasting can be
super beneficial for people.
So I probably recommended intermittent fasting for you as well.
Not a question, but a quick update.
Sharedness.
Why do you have to write for the meat on your program?
My most recent blood work came back incredible.
Lowest cancer marker scores ever.
Wow, almost not existed.
In literally no hormones circulating anymore.
I have never felt better and will forward you all my lab work.
Surely, thank you for all you do.
Thank you.
We'd love to have your testimony.
I haven't asked for testimony since the board
made us take our testimonial page down.
I haven't asked for testimony for only two years before that.
But if you guys have testimonials,
we'd love to have them.
Love that picture of you with your testimony too.
You could email them to me.
That would be wonderful.
I'd really much appreciate that.
We did put our testimony page back up, but not public.
It's only had a few pages to get to.
So and it's on our course.
We have some testimonial videos on some of our courses.
You may have seen that, but we didn't put our whole page back up.
So I missed this question here.
I had no carcinoma lung tumor is growing in size,
not apparently responding to traditional targeted drug therapy
nor to rife and might have been supplement therapies.
And colleges wants to start chemo-emetotherapy
for genetic markers of amplification proteins
that are reproducing during cell mitosis.
It feels like they want to treat symptoms to me.
What really is amplification?
How does it relate to original genetic mutated cells?
And what should I be considered doing right now?
Well, we should have a phone conversation,
but we've had people respond just tremendously
to immunotherapy.
So we've also had people respond horribly
to immunotherapy in their mind.
I honestly think we had one patient that passed away
two years ago, and his wife just swore.
It was the immunotherapy that killed him.
I'm not positive about that.
In granted, some people could respond horribly to a therapy.
We've had other people respond poorly to immunotherapy,
but we've had just miracles with it too.
It compels really well with the rife.
And I've told you before that there
is a study that just started at Mayo,
using immunotherapy and are of all immune
and are of all entourage.
Now, aloevia, immune, aloevia entourage.
They're using that coupled with immunotherapy, which
is kind of interesting.
So I'm not against immunotherapy.
If everything else isn't working,
I might want to look at doing another cheek swab too,
which you probably have a conversation.
What do you think about the budwag mixture?
So I'm very pro-using the budwag.
I do not believe everything that they say, they say that well,
it's not.
When you add the oil to the cottage cheese, it changes the cottage
cheese, so you don't have the effect of the dairy,
sorry, the physiological response is imaginary.
So you can't change the physiology of the dairy.
So if your cancer is driven by dairy,
that's my only concern with budwag.
So you're eating a cup of cottage cheese on a daily basis.
I guess if you've completely eliminated all other dairy
and you're just doing the budwag, we
have a number of people that are doing that.
I'm not against that.
So again, that's another thing to pray about.
Not against doing budwag.
I just don't want the dairy to be eating your cancer.
Can I use, I think this person means high pH water
with minerals and electrolytes in my coffee and a lot.
Sure, absolutely.
Our tap water seems to be somewhat salty.
How careful do I need to be with salt
about the ion foot bath?
Well, the amount of salt you have to play with.
So if your tap water has a lot of minerals in it,
you're going to need less salt in the ion pro-wave.
If it has less minerals in it, you're
going to need more salt.
Like if you're using reverse-susposis water
and your ion pro-wave, then you need to have more salt.
So you're going to have to play with that.
I think it lists at three quarters of a teaspoon or something.
The table splits.
You're going to have to play with that dosage.
You'll get the feel of what works best with your water.
Yes, came out of keto diet.
OK.
Yeah, certainly you could do.
You could try that keto diet.
If that, if your genetics looked that way too
and I gave that mention that you'd do good on a keto diet,
you could do it.
Just remember, keto diet are really hard to stick to and hard to do.
So, and the only thing you have to be really careful about
so many keto diets are just so high in dairy.
And you're ever dairy, even if dairy isn't a driver,
your cancer dairy's got so many growth hormones in it.
That's the difficult thing about being on a keto diet,
is that a lot of the things that you're eating on a keto diet
aren't necessarily good for you.
OK, you'll said, well, thank you so much.
I appreciate that.
I previously accessed the detox course videos.
A few days ago, I tried to access the auto-vealed course
unlike most other courses that just have a link to access the course.
OK, so you should not have to pay for the course
I think I thought I emailed Dustin to fix your log in.
I'm going to look at your, should it just be patient with me?
I'm just going to look at your accessibility real quick.
Raid, are you all the line?
If you can just access patties and make sure she's clicked
for the auto-vealed course, that would be great.
Because I don't know how to do that.
Yeah, as we should have that fix that will work.
So if it doesn't work by the end of this course,
I think Raid's on this.
She can fix it.
And if you call the office, we'll get that fix for you.
It's been two months since my itologist's
ethereal therapy did it start working immediately,
or it doesn't take a while.
Yes, I don't know.
Have you talked to the practitioner who did that?
I'm not familiar enough with it.
How fast that starts working?
We don't do that.
That's what you had down in Mexico.
So you're going to need to talk to them about an apologize.
Tony is going to get immunotherapy next after
light people in radiation.
Judy said a cheek swab in before he begins immunotherapy
or after.
I take it right after he does his first session.
Right after he does his first session,
because it's going to change his biochemistry.
So right after he does his first session, then send that in.
Is the cystitis setting on right good for all cysts?
No, cystitis is for bladder infections.
So that's what that's for.
Can I supplement with it to strike by patriotic cyst?
No, no, I wouldn't use that.
I would continue to run the patriotic programs that I gave you.
There may, I don't think there's just a cyst program in the right.
I have everything that I think you'll need in your overnight.
If you want to, if you're going to send a cheek swab,
did you say you're going to send a cheek swab in?
If you do, I can check your right setting
and see if I need to update your frequencies or not.
But that's for bladder infections.
I'm not sure why they did the immunotherapy
after the chemo and radiation.
But is there anything we should be asking in regard to that?
No, that's what they usually do.
So I mean, it used to be that you don't qualify
for immunotherapy unless you fail chemotherapy.
And it depends on the cancer.
Now it's becoming more acceptable.
Thank goodness.
I'm thinking that I am getting dried bumps on the scab on my face.
And this will be something coming out from detoxing.
My skin usually is not like this.
I'm wondering if castorile packs I do on my head and neck
are causing this.
I think if you do a cheek swab, so yeah, send that in.
There's just too many possibilities with that.
If you can email me a picture too, that would be great.
Try to get some close-ups of it as you can.
And then some, you said me as many pictures as you can.
That would be great.
Just set it to labs or info with colors.
Clinic and it'll come right to me.
Thank you.
OK, Patty, I'm looking at your thing.
You aren't checked for the autoimmune course.
So if you can try it again and make sure
you're using the same user name and password.
Hold on, let me uncheck it, save it.
Then I'm going to check it again.
So that it just kind of resets.
Let me do that again over here.
OK, I kind of reset it.
So hopefully that won't work now.
Yeah, if you logged into the member site,
you should be good to go.
Because you'll use your same user name and password
as the member site.
So now I just reset it, so give it another try.
If it doesn't work, I have no idea.
Because it looks like you're good for all the courses
of the member site here on my computer.
So hopefully that won't work.
If anybody else has had trouble getting into the courses,
just let us know just to email us.
OK, any other questions?
And spending one day at my sister-in-law's
who smokes at her house caused my cancer to get worse.
Normally, I'd say no.
But the truth is that anything that can just really,
you know, smoking has benzines in the smoke.
It has all sorts of other negative things in the smoke.
Very high oxidation rate of cigarette smoke.
If you're dealing with detoxification pathways
already, could it cause a flare-up?
Because it's going to cause inflammation possibly,
especially if you have antibodies to benzine, which isn't
that uncommon.
So you could look at what's called a Cyrex array 5.
And that will show that's an antibody test.
It will show if you have antibodies to cigarette smoke.
I can't wait till they add antibodies
to mRNA viruses into that test, hopefully.
Maybe they never will, just for medical legal reasons.
But I do know that we've had people
that went and visited people that were vaccinated.
And their cancer got worse noticeably
because they had a visible lymphoma and it got worse.
We've had lots of people that got vaccinated.
Their cancer was in remission and their cancer just took off.
And they passed away.
So I do know that exposure to chemicals and exposure
to things that cause inflammatory processes
and cell damage and oxidation can cause a cancer to grow.
So years ago, I would have said no,
but now we're just experiencing that more and more.
So I'd say yes.
Do you think that Michael Carfield has any treatments
that are worth getting?
Good question.
I just interviewed him on a matter's clinic podcast.
I liked him as a person, but I just talked to a person on the phone
a couple of weeks ago they went and visited him
and explored what he offered.
And they didn't like this clinic at all, but everybody's different.
So I don't know.
I really liked him.
I thought he was a really nice guy.
Personally, I don't know all the therapies that he has to offer.
He talked about what are two of them.
I thought, well, that's really neat.
So that's, I think something to explore
at least have a conversation that I think would be a good idea.
What are your thoughts on me doing a three day water fast?
So a three day water fast, the only negative,
we've talked about this a lot,
that the only negative about doing more than a 24 hour fast
for a cancer patient is that your IGF one levels go up.
So if that's a benefit, if you don't have cancer,
so doing a long term fast like three day water fast
once a month for a person who doesn't have cancer,
that's really beneficial.
You want your IGF one levels to go up.
That can help things grow.
That can help you rejuvenate things,
but it's generally considered that you don't want
your IGF one levels to go up
when you have active cancer.
So it's generally recommended that you don't do anything
more than a 24 hour fast if you have active cancer.
The only exception to that would be
if you're going to do IV chemotherapy and you,
we recommend a 24 hour fast to do it before your IV chemotherapy,
but some people recommend a 48 hour fast before that,
because you just want yourself so hungry
that they'll basically gobble up the chemotherapy.
That's the idea.
But so that's the whole idea.
It's just to stick to a 24 hour fast
and then also consider doing
time restricted eating as well.
Are fermented foods okay?
If you don't have histamine issues,
fermented foods are really good for you.
So if you have histamine issues
and histamine is driving your cancer,
those are more so breast cancer patients,
but histamine can drive colon cancer in such too.
So if histamine is an issue
then you don't want fermented foods.
You want to stay away from too much of that.
Do you have an interview of yourself
that is a good introduction to you
and your clinic that I can forward to some friends?
We have some on our website.
I have lots.
I mean, I could have, I could,
I'll be honest with you.
I have never once listened to one of my videos.
Not one.
I can't stand listening to myself.
So, but I'll ask my staff what they think
was a good interview.
We had a lot of comments on the breast cancer survivor,
Dr. B podcast, she interviewed me a couple of years ago
and a lot of really good comments on that,
but I will ask my staff what they think it is
and we should email you the link.
But thank you for even wanting to recommend us.
I appreciate that.
That's quite an honor.
What do you think of reverse osmosis water?
Well, personally, we have reverse osmosis water at our clinic.
No, our clinic is out in the country
but we have a lot of nitrates in the water.
So we do get a reverse osmosis unit
because that will take those out.
At my home, we live in the country
and we have a well also.
We do not have a reverse osmosis unit
because we haven't had our water tested
and it's like great.
So I want the nutrients that are in the water too
so I don't have a reverse osmosis.
But every time I did live in the city
where we had a chloride and fluoride,
we had a reverse osmosis unit.
A lot of people say, oh, that's not good
because you know your water's dead.
I'm sorry, but I'm not drinking my water
to get minerals from my water.
I'm drinking my water for the water.
So I'm getting minerals for my food.
So I don't buy that argument.
I think reverse osmosis is the best way to take out,
you know, other things and chemicals that, you know,
a just a simple carbon filter won't take out.
Carbon will take out a lot of the fluoride
and a lot of the chlorine but it's not gonna take out.
The nitrates is not gonna take out
any like heavy metals or mercury or arsenic
and things that are commonly in water.
So I am a fan of reverse osmosis.
Local practitioner told me that distilled water
is the only thing that takes out your radium.
Yeah, I don't know about that.
I don't know if that's true or not.
It's typically not a lot of your radium
in your water supplies.
But I mean, I've had people with your radium toxicity.
I had one guy who wanted to hear funny story.
It's not funny.
This guy had major problems, major colon problems.
That effect he came to me as a last ditch effort
because they were gonna actually remove
a large product of his colon.
He did not have cancer.
But he tested positive for your radium
but I thought, oh wait, I have no idea.
And he lived in an area where you could search the groundwater.
There's a website, I forgot the name of it.
It's on our website and I have a blog post about it.
But you could search the, you know, for local contaminants.
And not in his water supply, not in anything like that.
And then it turns out that his life has this collection
of, you know what that antique glassware is?
That's actually your radium glass
but they changed the name of it
because they used your radium in one or two.
To make the bomb, they changed the name of it
to carnival glass.
Well, that is your radium and especially the grade stuff.
What's in the wife has this huge collection of it.
And he was a builder.
They move every year, they build a spec house,
they sell a spec house, they move, build another spec house.
And he said, I have to move and grab,
I'm the one who has to handle all that glassware.
He was getting your radium toxicity for that glassware.
Not good.
So we did pull it out, which is so real bad.
So he got better.
And then you talk about what symptoms can happen
while using the right for cancer.
Well, some people, very small percentage of the people
can have kind of like detox symptoms,
the 90% plus don't have 80 symptom changes.
Now you will have symptom changes.
If you just started changing your diet
and you just started doing other things,
doing detoxes and stuff that you, you know,
you make any lifestyle change in your physiology changes,
you could have some detox type reactions.
The other thing that you can happen
when you're using the right is you can feel a little tingle
at the side of the cancer.
That's not everybody.
That's only maybe half the people,
maybe not even that much.
But other than that,
you're not going to notice any big symptom changes
from the right itself.
What are your thoughts on having a weekly Myers cocktail
I'm not a fan of this.
And the reason I'm not a fan of this
is because Myers cocktail IV is all synthetic B vitamins.
They're not a good source of supplements.
So I'm not a fan of that at all.
I'm going to keep taking all my subs.
I heard oral laitrel is not good
because it messes up stomach.
Is that true or not true?
That is just totally not true.
I mean, I've had,
we've been using oral laitrel for,
since the late 90s,
we've never had anybody have any stomach problems
except one person.
And that was a person who wasn't even supposed to be taking it.
And they took like 10 capsules at one time.
Without, I didn't even recommend it.
They had it and they took 10 capsules
and they got really sick for about six hours.
They were really sick, but then it passed.
But never had anybody have stomach problems with it.
You recommend high dose vitamin C for cancer.
Yeah, it can be really good.
But if I didn't recommend it in your testing,
then I wouldn't go out and look for it.
Like this person in the question said,
hey, we just got a fusion bar in my city.
I would like to try it.
Is it bad for colon cancer?
No, I wouldn't say it's bad for colon cancer.
So if he wants to try it, then go ahead and try it.
But in test, I wouldn't necessarily seek it out.
I have her take out the B complex in the buyer's cocktail.
Still, I think everything in it is synthetic.
I don't know why you want to take it.
I mean, it's not like you're like,
deficient in nutrient and said you're like,
your body is starving to death or something.
So that's the only,
that's the reason why it was created.
If a person is just totally famished of nutrition,
and they're just trying to get some nutrition back
in this person's body.
Otherwise, they're just selling you something.
So that's, I wouldn't do that.
My oncologist told me that hormone blockers,
which are shrinking my breast tumors,
is killing the cancer.
I remember you say that that's not true.
Your thoughts?
Well, no, no, I don't think the hormone blockers
are killing your cancer.
So understand that that's just the way he's explaining it to you.
So what are bad estrogens doing to estrogen positive tumor?
So bad estrogens are attaching to a receptor
the cell membrane of the cancer
called the beta receptor of the cell membrane in the cancer.
The beta receptor is an apoptotic receptor.
So it doesn't allow,
you're doing all this other stuff to kill the cancer.
You're using the right,
if you're doing all this nutrition,
you're stimulating your immune system,
or some might be doing keybalt therapy, et cetera, right?
And if you are blocking the cell death of that breast tumor
because you're not reducing the estrogens well enough
from a natural perspective,
or maybe you're not doing an natural perspective at all,
then it can keep the cell alive.
So when you get rid of the bad estrogens completely
because you're getting rid of all your estrogens
with a hormone, a robotase inhibitor type drug,
then you allow everything else that you are doing
to kill the cancer, to kill the cancer.
So you allow that process to take place better.
So I would say,
he's just explaining it to you in a more simplistic faction
because you're smarter than that, you're not buying it.
So I have felt depleted of my electrolytes.
That's why I did my ears, okay.
And I am familiar with curcumin IVs.
There's nothing wrong with that, for sure.
So yeah, any other questions?
Okay, well thanks for being on patty.
If you still can get out of the autoimmune course,
call back, call the clinic
and that's what we'll have to work on tomorrow
or something, I don't know what's going on then.
All right, know that I prayed for all you guys.
Thank you for your prayers for us.
And just continue the good fight, keep looking at the course,
keep looking at the member site, look at whatever's new
are there and the blogs if you can't fight anything,
make sure you give us a call, you can always make it a point
with me too.
All right, everybody, bye bye, have a good weekend.